[Music]
what's up Howard Stern its Ian
Somerhalder here I just got to tell you
for me and everyone at this soundstage
and Netflix so grateful that you decided
to check out the show I know you had a
question or two about the show and I
wanted to maybe add some clarity the
vampire of virus breaks out he's so
brilliant he has a way to neutralize the
vampire virus they go well never mind
that right now your buddy has turned
into a vampire you better go out and
capture him and bring him back the
doctor yeah by himself no other help
doesn't had a fire a gun not in the
doctor and this is the guy who could
invent a cure to save the entire you man
right all humanity I was ripping the
[ __ ] hair out of my head why the hell
would they send Swan out into the field
to catch a vampire at the risk of being
killed valid thought one who better to
go catch a vampire than a vampire well
at least a former vampire to the
government doesn't always make the best
decisions and three I'm getting these
scripts I'm stuck in a studio in a
boring ass lab you got to rewrite this
[ __ ] figure this [ __ ] out get Swan out
there give them a gun craft service is
better when you're on location I hope to
see you in New York on your show you're
the man thank you love you whoever wrote
this wrote it to make me crazy I'm
telling you I think they're only beaming
this show into my house and you know I'm
watching it I'm streaming it one after
another I love it
[Music]